so as promised this is my 1,000
subscriber thank you video and thank you
guys so much I never thought this
channel would reach a thousand
subscribers that's really cool you know
I started this channel back in college
just as a casual upload of cool science
things I learned in class that you
couldn't find in textbooks or that you
couldn't find in in common place and
when I finished college and started
working the 9 to 5 grind I kind of began
to notice that a lot of the skills and
info and knowledge I learned in school
was kind of fading away and kind of not
being used so I couldn't really call on
it to say oh yeah what was this or what
was that so I began to take the channel
a bit more serious as it means to keep
myself educated but also to keep you
guys informed as well about cool science
facts and things things happening in
science so thank you all so much I never
would have guessed this would would have
happened from a casual science YouTube
channel and I also have some cool
absolutely not cool some quick updates
it's kind of boring but just bear with
me so first off I will be posting more
frequently in the future I have a lot of
videos in the pipeline that I'm working
on they just take some time and I will
be taking more suggestions so make sure
you comment in the videos with more
science questions I love when you guys
do that so thank you for that
secondly I will be bringing back science
log Thursdays but only on topics I
really really want um I don't like to
vlog I don't like showing myself on
camera maybe I'm self-conscious or
what-have-you but it's not a particular
hobby of mine so I will be posting but
not all time and lastly I'll be starting
a lot more science experiments as I
should because this is a science Channel
right but um science experiments do help
to illustrate questions and answers so
that's going to be helpful to do however
science implies does get expensive
pretty quickly so I'll be setting up a
patreon to help fund my experiments I
have a lot of cool ideas that have not
been
on YouTube yeah I know that there's a
lot but these are some that have never
been done so I cannot wait to show you
guys so that's the video and once again
thank you all so much for watching it
means a lot to me and keep asking
questions thank you